وللمرة الثانية صواريخ امريكية
تتسكع في الاجواء الروسية
وبلاروسيا تنشر صواريخ روسيا في
اراضيها بل يحضر بوتين لكارثة كي
يرد على الولايات المتحدة
وواشنطن تهدد بعقوبات موجعة. فما
الذي يجري؟ زينينسكي يدعو بوتين
الى منازلة في حلبة المصارعة. لا
انصحك بذلك. واخيرا الاوروبيون
على قرار واحد وموسكو تجيب بهذا
الرد لصدهم. والمدمرات الروسية
والصينية تداعب امواج المحيط
الهادئ بينما الغرب يعيش حالة من
الهلع. وايران تستعطف بكين
والسبب دول الخليج علاقات غريبة
ومشبوهة بين تركيا واليونان.
وبعض الصواريخ. كم جونغ يرعب
الغرب بحرب الاقمار الصناعية تحت
اشراف والاردن على صفيح ساخن
وعمان تجمع دول الجوار لاجل
بغداد. السعودية لم ولن نقبل باي
اعتداء على اي شبر من اراضي
العراق ومصر تستورد اسلحة حربية
مرعبة. موسكو مرحبا بالحرب. قلق
عالمي واشارات امريكية تثير الشك
مع تحذير روسي وبعد اربعة صواريخ
ظهرت ستة صواريخ اخرى. لتعلن
الدفاع الروسية اسقاط اربعة
صواريخ الصنع في واضافت ان
دفاعاتها الجوية ايضا اعترضت ستة
صواريخ في فهل ترد موسكو هذه
المرة رد روسيا جاء من الجارة
الى روسيا. التي اكد رئيسها نشر
منظومات اربعمائة وصواريخ في
بلاده داعيا بوتين لمساعدة
بيلاروسيا في تطوير طائراتها
لحمل اسلحة نووية. ليرد بوتين ان
بلاده تعمل على تعزيز مشاريع
الطاقة النووية ومشاريع الغاز في
بلاروسيا. هناك حذر المتحدث باسم
الخارجية الامريكية بلاروسيا من
مغبة تقديم مزيد من الدعم لروسيا
في الحرب الاوكرانية بفرض المزيد
من العقوبات نظام لوكاشينكو على
حد تعبيره. لكن الكرملين نفى ان
يكون الهدف من زيارة الرئيس
بوتين لبلاروسيا هو اشراك مينسك
في العملية العسكرية الروسية في
اوكرانيا. وقال بوتين ان
بلاروسيا شريكة لموسكو في جميع
المجالات بما في ذلك الاقتصاد
ليضيف لوكاشينكو ان التبادل
التجاري بين البلدين ووصل الى
نحو واحد وثلاثين مليار دولار
على ان الى اربعين مليار دولار
نهاية العام الجاري. لكن الرئيس
الروسي امر بتعزيز امن الحدود
وفرض مزيد من اجراءات السلامة في
المناطق التي ضمتها بلاده وقال
ان المناورات المشتركة مع
بلاروسيا ضرورية في ظل التوترات
الراهنة. هنا استفزاز امريكي اخر
واشارة اخرى للصدام. فواشنطن
تشرف حاليا على تدريب القوات
اوكرانية لتشغيل منظومات باتريوت
في رومانيا بحسب سكاي نيوز.
ومصادر عسكرية تكشف ان الولايات
المتحدة لم تتخذ اي قرار سياسي
حول موعد ادخال منظومة باتريوت
الى كييف. لترد الخارجية الروسية
قائلة ان سياسة الولايات المتحدة
في اوكرانيا تدفع البلدين الى
حافة الاصطدام المباشر وتؤكد ان
جميع الاسلحة المرسلة سيتم
تعقبها وتدميرها. لننتقل الى
الرئيس الاوكراني مولود ميرسي
الذي طلب هذا الطلب غير المتوقع
حيث دعا فيه نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الى نزال في حلبة
المصارعة زينينسكي ذو الاربعة
والاربعين ربيعا اكد انه سيكون
سعيدا بمنازلة بوتين ذي السبعين
عاما وذلك بحسب تي اف ون
الفرنسية. برأيكم لمن تكون
الغلبة للمصارع والجاسوس الروسي
ام للممثل الكوميدي. ومن حلبة
المصارعة الى حلبة اوروبا
للطاقة. وبعد خلاف استمر لشهور
توصل الاوروبيون اخيرا الى اتفاق
بشأن اسعار الغاز بحيث لا يتجاوز
مائة وثمانين يورو لكل ميجاوات
في الساعة. مما يعني انتهاء
الخلاف. وتقول اوروبا انها خفضت
اعتمادها على الغاز الروسي تسعة
واربعين في المائة الى سبعة في
المائة من اجمالي احتياجها
وموسكو تتوعد برد مناسب. وفي
اوروبا ايضا لقاء لقادة شمال
اوروبا والبلطيق اضافة الى
هولندا لامداد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكرية والانسانية
والسلنسكي يدعو الى تسريع هذه
المساعدات خصوصا المتعلقة
بالدفاعات الجوية. روسيا المحيط
الهادئ لا يهدأ. خطوة صينية
جديدة وقلق الغرب يزداد اكثر.
لكن بكين لا تتوقف وتحضيرات
المستقبل مستمرة. حيث قالت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية ان روسيا والصين
ستجريان مناورات بحرية مشتركة
نهاية الشهر الحالي وستشمل اطلاق
صواريخ وقذائف مدفعية في بحر
الصين. والى روسيا تضم الصين دول
الخليج الى حلفائها لكن الغضب
جاء هذه المرة من ايران. فطهران
لا تزال تشعر بالامتعاض على ما
جرى في زيارة رئيس الصين الاخيرة
الى السعودية حتى انها قامت
بتسليم مذكرة احتجاج رسمية بعد
النقاط التي وردت في البيان
الختامي للقمة العربية الصينية
في السعودية التي عقدت الشهر
الجاري. وقبل ذلك ذكرت وكالة
الامريكية ان نائب رئيس مجلس
الدولة الصيني الذي سافر الى
ايران بعد زيارة رئيس الصين الى
السعودية تمت ازالته من المناصب
العليا في السلطة بالبلاد وهو ما
لم يعجب طهران. كيم يستعين
بشقيقته. لا عودة للوراء ولا
توقف في مكان واحد. كوريا
الشمالية تنتقل من مرحلة لاخرى
وبعد الصواريخ البحرية جاء دور
الاقمار الصناعية. حيث نشرت
وكالة الانباء المركزية الكورية
صورتين ثابتتين الاولى تظهر
اطلاق صاروخ والاخرى بالابيض
والاسود وتشير الى قمر صناعي حول
سطح الارض وفقا للوكالة فان
التجربة التي اجريت في موقع
سوهاج لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعية
في شمال غربي البلاد كانت تهدف
الى مراجعة قدرة كوريا الشمالي
على التصوير بالاقمار الصناعية
ونقل البيانات وانظمة التحكم
الارضية. ليس ذلك فقط بل ان
بيونج يانج اصدرت ايضا صورا
لعاصمة كوريا الجنوبية سيول
ومدينة انشون المجاورة لها حسب
ما قالته وكالة يوناب الكورية
الجنوبية للانباء. مع مجنون
كوريا مش حتقدر تغمض عينيك. ومن
كيم الى شقيقته لا حدود وبعد ان
نشرت امريكا طائرات نووية قرب
كوريا الشمالية خرجت شقيقته
كيميو جون قائلة ان المشككين في
قدرات صواريخ كوريا الشمالية
سيعلمون قريبا ما يمكن ان تفعله
تلك الصواريخ على ارض الواقع.
تركيا تعلن حربها التكتيكية.
تركيا تستخدم الطريقة الروسية يد
تفاوض ويد تحارب. في الوقت الذي
كان اردوجان يهدد اليونان بضربها
بصواريخ باليستية كشفت تقارير عن
اشياء اخرى كانت تجري خلف
الكواليس في بروكسل. حيث نظمت
العاصمة البلجيكية اجتماعا سريا
جمع مسؤولين من تركيا واليونان
بحسب وسائل اعلام يونانية. بينما
تقول انقرة ان اللقاء تناول سبل
اعادة احياء قنوات الاتصال بين
تركيا واليونان بعد الخلافات
الاخيرة. لماذا ازعجتنا يا
اردوغان بخطاباتك الحربية
والحماسية في الايام السابقة بل
تخبرنا انها مسرحية كي نقف ونصفق
لك؟ لكن بعد ان تقفل ستار
مفاوضاتك فهل جعل الاتراك
المفاوضات السرية السبيل لمضيهم
بصناعة قراراتهم الدولية؟
الاحداث والتطورات. في الاردن
يقام مؤتمر بغداد اذ يجتمع قادة
دول الجوار بهدف مناقشة تطورات
المحيط الاقليمي في المنطقة.
والسعودية تعلنها لن ولن نقبل
باي اعتداء على اي شبر من اراضي
العراق. الاحداث تشتعل في الاردن
مجددا. وبعد مقتل ضابط اردني.
الامن العام الاردني يكشف عن
مقتل ثلاثة من عناصره خلال
ملاحقة لمخربين. اللهم احفظ
الاردن فلتحمدوا الله وانظروا
لحال سوريا واليمن والعراق
ولبنان. لا تخرب بيوتكم بايديكم.
البيت الابيض يوافق على تسليم
البحرية المصرية عددا من السفن
والفرقاطات الحربية المتطورة
ومتعددة المهام. الصواريخ
الامريكية تجري مغامرة فوق اراض
روسية وموسكو تحذر. فماذا بعد
التحذير يا هؤلاء?